okay we have 15 seconds what's the goal
no the goal is to win the tournament is
3 2 1
what's my opinion on the Vienna Vienna
uh it's a city I've never been to
actually I've wanted to go to let's play
play g6 hey I'm the perspective thanks
for the bits
ok I'm playing this some kind of new
opening the Norwegian rats because it
gets players thinking from early on like
sometimes when you play garbage it just
confuses people I think this is already
like decent for black even though it
looks disgusting because we trade I
played out of five yeah this looks very
nice I can take again now let's close
things down the pawns are in some
smiling shape some V shape 25 and Bishop
d2 is coming I should have started with
Queen b6 that's okay it's a close
position I'll play rook c8 sin yeah V
for victory
like a Castle queenside - no no I feel
like my King should actually be here
it's so safe like there's no
breakthrough for white yeah I'm just
gonna slow play like my next moves are
this oh never mind
I have to do something here should
probably take open the C file oh I could
take on before maybe I'm fighting the
Queen now I check mm-hmm yeah b7 might
fall at some points that's gonna fall
very soon I don't know what's going on
here actually oh okay now I know what's
going on that's not good for me
completely forgot about that the Queen
III maybe check
accidental compensation what's going on
Rexy - I was of 93 I probably Brooksie -
is Queen b5 checked offends mean this
was okay to start with Calculon Queen b5
King f8 rook b3 rook c1 meet
oh no I keep oh I have Brooke c6 so I
keep messing up that's not good mm-hmm
now this is really bad now it's such a
cool position - okay let's Castle and go
in for the kill that's so bad though
rooks just hanging I'm just praying for
something we got 294 maybe it's still
tricky actually goes free nights
anything better
it likes not afraid
rook b8 maybe it doesn't quite work
pretty Queen d2 now okay so I'm down a
full rook but I have comp what's
defending all the key squares hmm that's
me
it's still really confusing
that's a funny move hmm oh don't meet me
I'm fighting a pawn should like he knew
g7 when I got the chance this is
terrifying check
I'm not seeing really any hope I have to
try this that's so sad
there's no stalemate traps either it's
so so sad
oh what a game I felt like it was very
close to winning like around here but
maybe not rook c1 no cuz there was
pinned of course I yeah also there's
Queen d1 it was close it was very close
okay
tough start that was a long game too I'm
tied for last place how many players
there's two seventeen so last place is
like 1200 okay
I'll probably play someone slightly
weaker do i beserk let's not desert I'm
trying to raise my rating and sorry if
I'm missing questions and the chats I'll
probably answer answer things after this
tournament okay so we have actually have
a fun line I'll take and there's e5 here
actually but then 94 let's play f3 cuz
he 594 I wasn't sure about
this is a very classic attack have this
move I think I'm just winning upon
actually
or maybe not there's queen d8 queen D
and I take me five huh this is
interesting
Arizona welcome okay
my things are looking very good so we
have multiple people from Arizona
multiple people from Montana okay the
king is going for a walk I mean there's
e5 is this move
I'm just preventing the king from coming
back so funny move on the plate you five
soon if King here I'll play this to
prevent King be seventh now so many
people from Arizona at least one person
from Canada Leah Brooklyn nice Oh el
capitan thanks for thanks for subbing oh
this is so close to meet
it's so close
okay Ponte excite win the Queen so keen
takes I was thinking Queen g5 there's
also a f4 when g5 Bishop i5 let's try
this fish about five out of G for
it's so close to me it's so close yet so
[Music]
it's so weird so close that's so weird
what to do I mean there's f4f words got
to be good I'm winning like both minor
pieces
okay the key is still exposed and
slightly disappointing that I wasn't
able to meet but yeah this is good
enough yes I mean I'm trying to control
all the squares around the king
oh that Bishop is kind of pinned okay
let's just take a pause
nohow box surviving like the king went
up and then went back
it's so weird okay
the end is near there's rookies seven
actually
okay there we go finally I having long
games I'm not gonna win the tournament
at this rate my first place has nine
points that's actually catchable no
thank you
the people's pot sir yeah not I'm not
able to take questions so thoroughly at
the moment but lay there all I'll stick
around
yeah I'm Boozer King my opponents below
mm Alba's irk but feel free like if
you're new to chess and you have like
newbie chess questions ask them in the
chat and theirs is usually at least a
few like experienced chess players
willing to answer
okay so we have a London usually 97's
not a great move because it blocks the
defence of the Queen Queen defending the
bishop expecting Queen b6 to defend the
pawn I prevent black from castling a
black still can't castle throwing to
check hmm yeah pequin was tied down to
the the night okay I just want to win
quickly
it's my one goal and not plunder a queen
and pre move this
hmm
okay the night should fall very soon
kingi sevens forest came out three minor
pieces our life is very good
where's the quickest wind probably
sacking on g6 hmm this is nice win the
Queen sack for meats okay let's go let's
get some momentum it's got some height
hey PP kk 7 7 7 gifting a sub to here
for chest fits all here for chest foods
welcome back oh you were having a crap
day but yeah if you see me streaming
hopefully your table and in a less
crappy way playing general checks
let's beserk again let's play london
again hudson Viking welcome back what is
this plea for Oh box playing a hippo
this is the best way to hunt the the
hippo was March 2h pawn now I want to
bring the knight to h5 yeah cuz the
bishop is just a target now I could play
f4 yeah we might so useful on h5 defends
at 4 cover Swamy key squares all Castle
queenside
[Music]
do this some idea of hitting that pine
actually I'm expecting back to Castle
queenside as well
okay yeah we're going to trade
but it's nice being up a piece the goal
the goal to win this quickly is the
seventh ranked domination it might be a
little bit tricky
okay simply listen this there we go
this is a me threat
hmm this is also a made threats okay
that was nice
got the seven three in control
hey I'm top ten let's go first place has
17 points Wow yeah so I have the slow
starts but I'm trying to work my way
back
young rule welcome back why don't I play
Athens candids that's yeah it's an
opening I just haven't studied so
they're really for for either color so
I'm guessing at some point in my my
chest career I'll go through and Evans
gambit phase and just keep reminding me
and eventually I'll get around to
studying it Queens almost trapped 24
only for Bishop e5 but Bishop e5 runs
into this okay yeah last last few
opponents are falling into trouble early
and tides are turning fan vine hold
welcome back okay let's stick with the
bishop on the play eith five like a
castle
oh boy this move just simple idea of c-5
oh if I would prepare vision a6 and
vision basics is actually like just so
devastating whoa it's bicycle bicycle
gifting five subs I'll read off the sub
names
my position is relatively good things
bicycle
we have frizzy on 999 we have fix should
stay somewhat focused to play this move
is not letting me pre move I was weird I
think that was a mouse problem Favre
okay so we have frizzy on we have oh we
almost have a meat that's good yeah this
is gonna end pretty badly for white
fixie far of are we supposed to shout
out to the wizard and brick villager in
it thanks again bicycle that's taking
night yeah White's not surviving this
rook to yet coming
we also have salmon salmon numbers
thanks for subbing with twitch crime and
president irrelevance kind of rhymes
you just got nervous and make awful
opening moves if you got nervous just
take a deep breath dessert and don't
play awful moves I'll good to see you
the emotes yeah life is good
I wasted ten seconds Center enjoying the
emotes the time well-spent
okay this is a nice opening whenever the
bishop develops it means the b-pawn is
not defended I can apply some early
pressure oh I see five kind of a loud
hmm I'll take him Knight f3 I want to
play e6 and win g6 yeah this is nice
where's my mates okay let's take another
pond
ooh what does this move it's a free
queen I guess I can take it okay that
was a nice game hey first place Wow
five desert no for berserk wins in a row
five five points in a row or no three
five points in a row I'm getting
confused numbers are just confusing I
guess oh thank you the people's pot sir
thanks for stopping by
what is this opening the d5 this d5 c5
hmm why wants to play b4 lay Bishop g4
just focus on developing I wanna bring
my knife here Oh tricky tricky that
doesn't work though cuz Queen h4 I'll
win the bishop Hey Jude how's it going
or that was just some saying at house
someone saying hey dude fire King how's
it going a walk a bar is fighting for
the top 200 I'll still go for some
meeting attack maybe there's some fork
let's got some fork my emotes and soon
to be oh let's say soon-to-be Connect
four
yeah Connect four so nice never too late
to castle let's attack yeah again the
quickest way to win is the second-ranked
domination but how do I win
that's close
where's the win I'll just take that
yeah white was threatening meat there
that's be slightly careful hey we have
we have emotes we have naked Yeti
nine-nine thanks for setting weights
going for the King side attack with the
king okay
extending the lead yeah that first game
that I lost it felt like it took forever
but now that feels forever ago it's
weird how time works over an hour left
oh yeah I think I can kind of stay chill
what's a play I forgot to Missouri I'll
play a stacker gambit
well it's it's a Kady 707 gifting subs
thanks so much
also white kind of played a dubious line
I think
thanks so much a Kady I'll read off the
sub names as soon as I got a chance we
have waited white have Queen each five
white may have had Queen h5 there okay
we have pie man 5:35 ricado oom Astro
sarov XD and Vela allure yeah thanks so
much I appreciate that leadership have
to be careful here
no weights applying pressure it's a
little bit unsettling why of all my
minor pieces developed I just want to
play this and this that's a good move
I'm kind of scared there's so many pins
all over the place how do I deal with
this oh this is so terrifying I just
lose it I'd better not be losing this
what do I do here like what do I do
Queen d6 doesn't work though I guess I
have to give up a piece yeah that's kind
of sad I'm just losing back a piece I'm
gonna be down two pawns okay well this
is how you you try and fight when things
go wrong in life you you can't give up
hope okay I'm not gonna get distracted
by the chats or the tea have to focus I
just want a fork that's all I wanted to
it's actually hard for white to defend
my Queens covering this I can still fork
huh I kind of worked out like white
saved the pond but not the the forking
square I didn't thank someone for a raid
oh thanks for the raid I don't think it
made a sound thank you aha where was it
thank you someone for the raid Oh mister
her ologist thanks for reading with a
party of 48 thanks so much
I completely missed it I told you guys I
was not going to get distracted but now
I'm getting distracted what to do let's
play this move hey it's a donation
thanks for the five dollars let's play
play this move I'm defending g7 I just
want to play this and trade everything
yeah who was that
Oh clan dish thanks for thanks so much
okay let's focus not been focusing this
game even though I've been trying I want
to play a four trap the bishop hmm c5
doesn't quite work or does it doesn't
quite work
it was rook t1
hmm I'm not sure what to do here
95 looks risky though oh I might trap
the bishop actually cuz I coming from
behind I'm the bishop strapped what is
this
although I can take if I take there's
pawn push to take with king queen d4 my
getting beaten
I don't think I'm getting me that don't
meet me that's a good move
white has an incredible win here but
everyone be quiet okay let's play this
move okay white miss incredible wind
white still has a win
Wow oh there's that too oh I'm getting
four - no I got forked again now you die
I lost Oh Oh what I was so like so
impressed by this potential incredible
win look at this
yeah even like before all this pawn push
so after rook takes a to Y can take
takes a mini seven I can't defend the
pawn my Queens pinned and if takes takes
oh wait no I it's not a win live King f7
nevermind
white played well there it's g4 h 4 it
was a good plan and then I went terribly
wrong
I got sold a long time anti-tilt yeah am
I even on tilt yeah I'm on tilts ooh I'm
in second place I lost rating points I'm
supposed to be raising my rating not
lowering my rating
Oh Val old music from Australia what
time is it there it's got to be it's got
to be some time where there's sunlight
okay let's not those are gonna try and
get back on track I'll have another
London what's tilt it's when things are
not aligned
what's the theory here queen bee one in
queen bee ones caught in my pad line
ideas to just control the square root of
C for I am Bishop c2
I'm doing to win upon hmm you dig with
nights like f4 it's interesting it's
kind of like a stone wall set up now
still controlling e4
Oh probably like Castle kingside
hmm I'm tempted to take two I'm very
tempted to take let's take an f5 why not
this is so risky because I'm thinking
about sacking butts so risky
yeah I sack a pawn Black has triple
pawns almost quadruple pawns so the idea
this is the whole idea it's just like
tear apart the King and meat also play
Halo thanks for subbing at tier 1
I'm just envisioning like queen g4 king
here and then rogue age three mates how
difficult can it be okay we might trade
Queens yeah I could win back the bishop
though I still have some attack and
pawns are actually you know this is a
good kind of transformation they rock f1
Rick aged six coming or not you take d5
yeah cuz rookie six I have work here
here here here here here here I win the
bishop
I think things are under control
it's a weird game oh there's Bishop e5
and this move ID Orochi 3 yeah I was
dreaming of d5 sometimes it's hard to
achieve your dreams
ok now I'm dreaming of like he needs 7
wreckage 2 means or yes we can trade
rooks I'm finding the bishop oh I missed
it's ok that was nice if you have a
question ask your question but I might
not see it because I'm trying to stay
focused on the game play this move but
hopefully it like if you have a question
other people can answer that's the whole
point of Chad's to have chatter play for
so many ways to win now where's my meat
let's just take let's go all right so I
have two losses in this tournament got
some reading from that game okay playing
a decently high rated player how long
have I been playing just seriously for
the last like 20 minutes ooh Halloween
ha ha ha that's a Halloween a it's
basically I don't know if I want to
accept contaminated bits but yeah be
safe wash your hands yeah take and take
whatever measures are are needed
that's scary I was gonna go - uh yeah
I've said this a few times I was gonna
go to Vietnam in March but the whole
thing got cancelled because of
coronavirus what's having its impact
this move but thanks for the thousand
bits
I mean I'll I'll accept them if they're
clean if they're not clean I'll wash
them the scheme was a scheme an h4 makes
some sense my h4 Bishop takes t3
and the night of five g4g for tonight
each for is interesting I just want to
double up on the the e-file now maybe
even triple up still ideas of this yeah
I'm just trying to find harmony hmm
night h4
now I wanted to make 9h for work nice
working g3 and doesn't quite work
there's some idea of bringing the night
to a forward just attack the pond it's
kind of random but yeah what else did
you I'm down a ton of time yeah it's
time management but the positions very
nice these pawns are targeted ok White's
going crazy it's actually a good move
play this
I'm scared to Bishop c7 also that's
scary too hmm rookie seven I could just
push up on don't make me each six is
terrifying
oh that's not a free rook hmm hoping
this works yeah I probably doesn't work
though the Queen uh fades
a position so delicate let's try this
sacking the queen those has gambit style
about to make a new queen oh that's so
sad
wow how did white give me a draw - why
just gave me a draw there Wow white
plate g5 it's just an easy draw that's
so sad I was so tilted Wi-Fi g5 what a
terrible g5 is just a draw oh it's so
sad
Sonya with the sympathy bits maybe I
deserve those those dirty her on the
fire spits after that keen thanks Sonia
welcome back g5 move that's the worst g5
I've ever seen but it still worked
because it's g5 ok let's play let's play
aggressively ooh
opponent was working back that's what I
like to see play Grand Prix attack
this is a very fun line ID for putting
teams kind of prepared hey let's move
okay this is actually very very nice now
that pawns pinned to the king I'll play
Knight d5 knight c6 IV just nine of six
check I've shown a very similar line in
a saint with chess club black shirt this
is uh usually why black should not take
this way this Bishop becomes too
powerful everything's just it's
overwhelming okay
trying to make a comeback one points out
of first that's kind of close you're
moving from Oh from Singapore to Toronto
well that's closer to America must be a
big move I've never been to I've been to
Toronto I flew through Toronto do I play
here was this move I'll play d4
trying to remember my my prep here
h5
so the Bishop's coming to see for I
guess I'll take I wanted to trade off my
dark-squared bishop I heard there is
isn't there a chest pub in Toronto I
keep seeing that on I think Instagram
somewhere pretty sure Toronto has a
decent chess scene I'm speaking of chess
let's focus on chess Oh what does this
move it's a move I'll play after
thinking f7 defend the pawn if Queen g4
i play g6
yeah just Google Google Pub chest hirato
I think that's the thing I just want to
trade Queens g5 let's go
and this is so passive it's so passive
I just want to be aggressive opponents
hire either than me - you're threatening
the Queen trade yeah maybe it's not so
bad
we're not 3g for I can't really move
there
and it's not so comfortable I want to
win see five repeat five is a move
that's a move I can take though oh but
I'm losing exchange maybe I get some
condensation at the rook
that's a good move hmm cuz I really
don't want to lose my a pawn but I'm
probably going to have to clubbing the
night to be four and I'll win see - oh
there is not five
please don't played out of five nine
five I have 96 attacking and defending
that's so scary
yeah that's terrifying I have to push my
a pawn and hope for the best
it's not working out
okay it's kind of working out
there we go let's go
ah that was intense I was I was losing
and then some somehow I won okay
Zurich so much adrenaline hmm
I'm tied for first let's go yeah time
pressure so much pressure I like this
position this is very pleasant some
sight space there's no Bishop c4 yeah I
think my opponent is some some
opportunities but I'll take the wind
I Bishop g5
what to do here I'm just comes to g3
yeah the pawns very well-supported gives
me nice nice space some idea of 94 never
mind
now if the bishop moves I have e6
unleashing the beasts the annex chess
club never heard of that but yeah do
your research I was in Montreal Montreal
has a a good chess scene too
also I'm winning a bishop or a queen
okay
hey backhand first got my five working
points where am i from
from the Chicago area spends these days
I spend most of my time in st. Louis I'm
still I still travel a decent amount
I'll be going to Columbus next month or
just over a month okay mmm let's hold
off on deserting it's kind of a fun line
blog knows what what to do
I just want to take the lights
and the center seems delicates don't
know if I can punish black don't know
play this takes takes takes I mean
there's Queen c2 maybe Queen b3 play
positionally oh come to my club where's
your club
you'll pay for my flights that's a nice
offer
Oh in Woodbine mall but where is that I
have not been following the context
there should be five I could also take
I'm taking looks very attractive mm-hmm
yeah the problem for black is this pawn
it's a long term weakness some ideas of
rook T 194 oh it's in Toronto yeah I'm
not sure when I'll make it back to
Canada I was actually I was invited to
play a tournament in Montreal in March
and I turned down the invitation because
I thought I was going to Vietnam I know
I'm not going to Vietnam so what to do
maybe five now the pawns actually well
defended now some c4 ideas could take
and this move too
hmm that's kind of weird oh that's
probably a blunder cuz Bishop takes
let's just take take and then I still
this move
oh there's rook 45 the threats
Wow I'll take an rook d4 so material is
equal its weird structure though I like
the structure especially if we trade on
d4 Vietnam is worth the trip for food
mmm food I've been going to a lot of
Vietnamese restaurants lately oh that's
some move could take out for we're about
to trade a lot of stuff I was careless
ceefor doesn't quite do enough work okay
I'll take this and then do this the nice
thing is whatever pawn black takes I
might ak7 I threaten meat that's still
slightly preferable structure this pawns
weak
no offense so pawn boo freak lon okay it
takes work
could just push the e-pawn maybe okay
I'm looking for meeting ideas it's very
close to mate
if g6 forgot sevens means ooh I wasn't a
slip I was a bad mouse up to
oh that's tricky I'm trickier this is
winning
let's go how would an end game that was
a weird end game Wow
I mean the position was drawn like black
can check me here it's probably the
easiest draw but then once we trade
rooks actually I could play this first
and it's winning but yeah this is nice
cuz Akina is just more active and yeah
this is like UNSTOPABLES looks long it
doesn't matter whose move it has blacks
always gonna be looks wand okay I got
four points there twenty seven minutes
left I'm trying to stay awake be hard to
stay awake sometimes
oh hi from Israel I'm nice it's 8:00 in
the morning
Wow good morning not sure why I'm the
sucking I just want to extend my lead
oh I lost a pawn oops I was bad it's not
a good game oh I guess I'll take Enrique
seven this is looking very very bad I'm
just down a pawn
we could have taken on f6 now maybe I
can untangle a little bits and T fives
coming I'll play rugby aids now a d5 I
take B - oh my rooks attacked I queen he
aids this is so difficult every move is
a plunder what is this
97 the threat such a bad position to
take
that's a good move
I'm not sure with my finance okay my
fans to play King g7 over defend the
pawn and lose f6 oh yeah yeah so I'm
only down three pawns
this is so so bad I don't know why I'm
playing the song it's so sad that
happens play this move I'm not resigning
because I have rooks quirks can be
tricky sometimes other times are not
tricky
maybe activate my king I'm trying
something here
like what do I do such a difficult
position
it's always like the outside hope of
stalemate I okay I was trying to set up
this rosin trap but yeah doesn't work oh
I'm not in first place anymore oh this
is this is close I thought I had a big
lead
Costin Jarl thanks for for subbing I
should have resigned I didn't realize
the turn in standings
okay let's some play aggressively
okay Center for trick Costco card thanks
for subbing - I need to win and win
games quickly I was hoping for this like
Bishop takes H to trap and this is also
very pleasant
yeah there's pins lurking everywhere
five looming play this move the Queen
was kind of hanging that my queen was
also hanging what I have six I take it
okay let's go
catching up to do ooh I lost to this
opponent twice already
let's not beserk I'll just play my main
line okay we'll accept amaura
it's an interesting line it's a fishing
pole trap it's a very interesting line I
really like the fact my points thinking
I'm 1394 now everyone doesn't move
routine 127
there's b5 also 95 maybe 5 yeah my
nights been attacked by the pond for
ages now Wow
oh it finally gives in oh that's a good
move can I take can I get the weight
with that takes boat s can't it takes
takes it's so interesting looking it
kind of looks working I have to it looks
so cool oh no my queen but then I take I
threaten mates if at three I win the
rook it's so cool it's so so cool look
at this rook h1 so hard to stop and then
f3 I taking f2 or take steam when I
threatened to Queen yes there's Bishop
e3 oh wait
oh the pawn was hanging oh I should have
taken maybe I don't know wait what's the
material I'm just down the Queen I'm
just down the Queen
oh that's so tragic I can Castle hmm
that doesn't work what happened to my
position to play g5
oh that looks about to get trapped hmm
something like terribly wrong here
[Music]
everything's going wrong this is so so
bad oh it's such a cool move - I feel so
broken f6 is such a sad move to play
many pawns do I have
I've broken three pawns for a queen that
move actually gives me some hope
lyrics are gonna get active now oh how's
a good move this ah that doesn't help at
all only helps white
this is so unfortunate I'm losing this
team b3 good move okay oh I felt so
brilliant at a moment but now I feel so
sad yeah this is oh I died just lose I
just lost for the top player - I didn't
realize I was playing for first place
Oh facepalm I need a miracle to win this
no okay
after the berserk and have to play
quickly I had this position earlier
Queen b5 was played earlier play this
move attacking stuff
hitting the pond
I don't know what's going on it's so
weird
but if takes takes I'm fighting you
Bishop D Bishop c5 maybe yeah I mean
there's so much pressure against all the
Knights and Queen in the pawn and the b7
pawn and Bishop take here what is this
what's going on
where does the Queen move just ee7 upon
to do this actually looks nice now I
think I just messed everything up but
you're still hope at age five week
before Bishop takes h5
how does this not seeing the
breakthrough
okay it's a draw
uh I tried I tried a little bit slow
with the mouse to do I got my one points
man I was interesting I got a winning
end game and then I was at one time it's
not easy
okay trying to finish strong let's play
Knight of three if I can move the pieces
that's a good move is this European
friendly
I guess it's morning in Europe now
you're welcome okay now I'm just trying
to attack
it's gonna take a big miracle at 7:00
a.m. in Norway nice it's morning
everywhere maybe Australia it's like
afternoon okay so I opened the file fish
it's targeted I want to play 94 good
move it's dangerous this is so
terrifying
maybe now it's less terrifying ready to
castle ooh but then queen up for bikini
- keenie - rocky one
is it lunchtime in India anyone from
India watching
it's always someone ok fuel momentum is
shifting just don't want to get meted
[Music]
okay life is good
yeah okay six coming there's one check
that's your offer okay to berserk for
points out of the lead hoping for at
least like two more games
some interesting line trying to get my
my classic attack Bishop h3 doesn't work
and g5 might be necessary yes
non-threatening g5 kick the neither than
win each three that's a good move
and G fives gonna be very difficult to
play especially in this case okay so I
have some idea rookie Yates and I'm down
two pawns really just going for broke
hmm of all the way back and darks far
between now bishops e7f ones taking a
lot of time hey it's bits g5 who is that
are those bicycle yeah well gee fuh the
G pons pinned blacks or White's friend
to me me on on g7 I can win a four maybe
ooh this is really bad
this is really really bad well maybe
it's not so bad it's still pretty bad
yeah if we go for a dirty flag
I need a miracle
someone saved me
Oh
shout out to Baltimore what I do here
it's so unpleasant it's so unpleasant
I'm a long time though surprisingly yes
let's go dirty flag let's go
uh-oh first place is true oh but first
place is playing a 1600 tie ok I think I
have to settle for a second or oh I'm in
third right now okay to play ultra-fast
yeah I can't let my opponents time be
greater than the tournament time they
make if that makes sense
no I won the Queen's like castle
knocking d1 go too early
okay still some pressure though I'll
play C 3 and C 2 so basically I can't
fault a little minute
running mate
the tricky move rook takes h1 and then I
play Bishop g5 it was very tricky
that was a really good move I'm down the
piece now
I have this move this is a good try
Oh back in Queen no blacks queening
takes and Queen I can't stop it but the
plunge saw through my oh I miss maiden
one oh but I have been one yes let's go
ah I was trying to reverse stream smite
my opponent oh I'm in first oh I'm in
first I'm in first wait this guy is
playing but I don't know that's gonna
finish also this guy I think is playing
too
Wow wait I might win this so von von
Neumann drew a 1600 I guess drew a 1600
Wow the pressure Wow
I might win this I just need the
tournament time to run out and get cance
oh oh this is not looking good this
person could catch up hoping black
doesn't resign though if 10 seconds left
in the tournament Wow
I might win this the longest 7 seconds
ever let's go let's go I won this while
I came back I came back it's a miracle I
got my miracle oh man I was getting
smashed and I cracked so many times
under pressure but somehow somehow it
ended it ended well wow what a
tournament maybe I'll put that on
YouTube surprise finish it's a miracle
and John John Davis is challenging me I
could play John shoutout to John hello
to YouTube
wow the tournament yeah that last game
that last game maybe I should explain
so I was I was kind of hoping my
opponent was watching the stream whoa
it's Gotham chess what's up Gotham chess
that's like the fourth or fifth rate
tonight's shout out to Gotham chess
people watching in the future on YouTube
I probably haven't ended the video yet
you can check out Gotham chess on Twitch
and on YouTube thanks so much levy yeah
if you're just joining I just finished a
very heart-wrenching tournament and I
was I was in second for a long time and
somehow I finished in first yeah things
love HS so this was a clincher and yeah
in this moment I I was hoping my
opponent was watching the stream and
would fall into my trap of if if Queens
takes or it takes Queens I meet because
bishops are strong but what happened the
game I was so disappointed my opponent
didn't play this
I forgot I have made him one and I took
but then thankfully I still had me in
one one of messy finish man I was just
such a mess of a tournament oh I was
like a dirty miracle that'll be the name
of the YouTube video something about a
dirty miracle okay people in the future
on YouTube thanks for watching twitch
chat say hi to YouTube YouTube
commenters say hi to twitch chat you all
might be the same people but that's okay